I do want to talk about something
serious for just one moment you've all
heard about this there's been a lot of
reports out there about a new drug
called bath salts and people who I can
tell I could tell when you walked in
yeah people who smoke the drug behave
unpredictably they've been known to rip
off all their clothes and run around
screaming sometimes they even attack
people like zombies this can all be
pretty scary it's been getting a lot of
attention in the media but what about
the people who actually have positive
experiences on bath salts how come we
never hear about them that's why I
wanted to introduce a friend of ours
he's an exception to the rule Ronnie
sunshine the incredibly helpful bath
salts addict
[Applause]
well it's Ronnie's sunshine smoking bath
salts having a good time
[Music]
need to spend a day bath salts are
addictive and fooling
they make bloodthirsty zombies out of
you and
Bharani Sunshine's change
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Ronni
[Applause]
[Music]
that actor has a child alright
[Laughter]